keine handys keine kreditklemme stecken
eigentlich kann ich nicht gespürt
vielleicht gehen die nicht probieren das
geht jetzt wieder also polizist haben
wir schon hinterherrufen stehen bleiben
und wir dachten was geht jetzt glaube
ich ein polizeiauto gesagt bislang geht
[Musik]
leute ganz kurz bevor es weitergeht ich
finde das lohnt sich nicht darüber jetzt
noch so ein dummes videos machen
aber mich wird es mega freuen wenn ihr
mal auf instagram geht weil ich habe da
noch was gerade in meine story gepostet
bezüglich der sache mit zdf und ich
glaub ich brauchte einfach nochmal so
eure hilfe also wäre cool wenn möglichst
viele von euch oder ich habe ein video
zugeschickt bekommen da passiert halt
was drin und da dachte ich mir ja kommen
dann tue ich das einfach mal meine story
vor dass deine leute auf das mal zu
verbreiten so ein bisschen ich mal
gespannt ob da noch eine reaktion darauf
kommt weil bis jetzt kann mir absolut
noch gar nichts und das finde ich ein
bisschen das war nicht ein bisschen
feige
das ist ein gutes wort ich muss gerade
voll lange überlegen jetzt geht es
weiter mit diesem video also geht also
geht auf instagram da hat sich alex wie
wird nicht mehr freuen und jetzt geht's
hier weiter als gedacht und herzlich
willkommen feiern wie ja ich muss
vielleicht gerade leute mit einer
wirklich ja sehr spontan nächtlichen
aktion ich bin jetzt irgendwie mal auf
die idee gekommen und wir machen das
jetzt relativ spät abends also sie haben
schon 00 uhr jetzt weil halt möglichst
wenig los ist und zwar habe ich ja
irgendwann mal dieses video gemacht
automaten produkte 24 stunden nur
automaten produkte probieren oder testen
mehr euro 20 für die energie es habe ich
noch 81 aber ich habe eine gute nummer
so dass hier ist auch gut und es gibt
jede menge automaten die sind alle schön
gefüllt und ich habe mir einfach mal
gedacht kaufst du denn mal eher das herz
sich erstmal total thumann ist es
vermutlich auch nicht keine ahnung ich
habe noch nie so einen leeren automaten
gesehen und stellt euch mal vor ihr holz
morgens zur arbeit an der bahn noch ein
schöner cola kaufen am automaten einfach
alles leer mit den ganzen sachen wäre da
natürlich irgendetwas sinnvolles machen
wir schauen einfach mal ob das überhaupt
geht weil keine ahnung ich würde sagen
kommt einfach mal mit begehrens erst ein
bisschen geld abheben
so leute jetzt geht es hier noch kurze
geld abheben
die frage ist kriege ich hier münzen ja
weil ich habe jetzt leider nur scheine
bekommen einige automaten funktionieren
aber auch mit scheinen so leute ich
glaube das schwierigste wir erstmal
werden ein automat zu finden wo man
überhaupt jetzt noch irgendwie zugang zu
hat oder wo auch nicht zu viele leute
sind wir sind jetzt hier bei der ersten
s bahn station und schauen ob sie
irgendwo ein gibt jetzt hab ich eben
schon wieder auf der score von bock
darauf zu laufen da ist aber jemand
flink hat wohl nichts gefunden hast du
nichts
boney m sprint sagt man einer community
fast sicher nicht sehr gut
nächster versuch
na ja das waren wieder keine sonstigen
sie scheiß automaten immer überall wenn
man sie nicht braucht man fangen jetzt
einfach zum hauptbahnhof oder nicht
sollte wir sind uns am hauptbahnhof nach
ungefähr einer stunde oder so ich habe
da oben schon mal gesehen ganz wichtig
schreibt mir jetzt in die kommentare was
glaubt ihr wie teuer wird es sein um den
ganzen automaten leer zu räumen schreibt
jetzt in die kommentare der nächsten run
die kriegt eine überraschung losgeht was
du schon recht überlege mir dass das
objekt der begierde aber nach zum
beispiel sind nur getränke drin so leute
wir haben jetzt ein automat gefunden den
ich jetzt mal lehrerin wäre das gute ist
gekommen mit karte zahlen sonst wird das
gar nicht gehen also es wird auf jeden
fall sehr tief in den geldbeutel gehen
aber ich gucke jetzt einmal also was
meinst du mit uns kosten 180
das ist hier eine kreditkarte machen wir
das jetzt
warnung abgelehnt machen sie mal so
durch
wie lange wird das dauern
das gefährt machen
eine halbe stunde
diese schätzen
heute dass wir so fucking lange dauern
du musst ja gar nicht die ganze zeit für
die welt sehen freising ist leer und du
machst einfach nur so zwischensequenz
magdeburg mit kinderspielen
wie lang ist
[Musik]
es ist halt so maximal stumpf morgens
richtig auf gut auf meine dieser
rechnung der bankberater so anrufen
nacheinander so 1000 bit klick klick
schon fast leer war kann es nicht mehr
ausstellen
jetzt geht's wieder ach das ist das
letzte treffen wenn die leute das letzte
tricks kommt
kommen wir zum ersten mal diese reihe
leer okay natürlich zeigt mal wieder
finden hier das sind kekse dessen 1234
kekse 1 reiter diesen hotels
das sind doch locker da sieht man das
ist ein locker 55 stück
da kommen wir als 24 du musst du
eingeben dies ändert seine kreditkarte
irgendwann gesperrt eigentlich kann ich
nicht gesperrt werden vielleicht gehen
die nicht probieren ein anderes das geht
jetzt wieder leute das problem ist
dieser automat ist irgendwie ein
bisschen am arsch diese 24 zum beispiel
funktioniert gab mir wünschen dass
überhaupt heimtransport ihren sitz haben
ich kann ja nicht erst abgeräumt heute
ja wir machen jetzt hier erstmal an kant
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder auf
ich habe mir extra sagen sagt dabei da
kann man das alles ein
frau
ja und verwandten hotel ans lernen dort
zwischenstand
zwei jahren war schon wirklich probleme
in armen abend 19
foto passt nicht weitermachen
aber ist doch noch gar nicht halb zehn
in deutschland
er macht das nicht
bonn
es ist ja eigentlich wollte ich hier
anfangen mit kleingeld auf ihrer visa
kunden benutzungs wurden verdächtige
aktivitäten heute okay eigentlich hatte
ich davor das ganz normal zu kaufen mit
münzen deswegen waren wir eben bei
münzautomaten gab es dazu keine ahnung
so dass kurze war das ging jetzt hier
mit visa jetzt kriege ich hier die
nachricht dass man eine visacard
gesperrt wurde
auf ihrer visa card planer war wurden
verdächtige aktivitäten entdeckt ihre
kartennummer wurde vorübergehend
deaktiviert kontaktieren sie uns
umgehend unter der rufnummer blablabla
das dumme ist jetzt nur nicht viel geld
haben schon ausgeben bestimmt 50 euro
oder okay sagen wir 45 und der automatik
hässlich machen wir haben noch münzen ja
aber nur 10 euro maximal ich ärger mich
jetzt selber was machen wir jetzt ein
kind geblieben
ja ich kann mit der rc noch geld junger
alter wären jetzt schon halb zwei uhr
müssen alle münzen machen das menschlein
lassen ich hab keinen bock jährlich also
ich finde erst einmal das wichtigste
wenn man keinen spaß mehr hat irgendwas
zu drehen dann habe ich auch keinen bock
mehr was auch wir machen das jetzt schon
geschenkt das einfach leute die hier
rumlaufen die sich bestimmt freuen
werden über basis zeiten und nachfrage
wieder nach hause und dann haben wir
trotzdem was einigermaßen gutes gemacht
auch wenn ich eigentlich kann ich morgen
erst mal einen bankkollegen du kannst du
ja vielleicht noch mal machen untertags
leute meinen blog habt dass ich das
wirklich mal dann halt noch mal
versuchen nach oben dar und es tut mir
wirklich leid dass es nicht geklappt hat
und ich bin wirklich so jemand ich will
das eigentlich seine mannschaft wolle
morgen kommt direkt bei franco leute die
nächsten aufnahmen wurden leider ohne
sound aufgenommen das mikrofon man
nämlich aus deswegen kann so wie das
jetzt bestmöglich nach zu
synchronisieren weil da ging richtig
action ab die sind dann noch mal in die
stadt gefahren weil am dom halt
irgendwie gar nichts mehr los war und
ich wollte heute noch irgendwann diese
sachen schenken dass ich bestimmt
darüber freuen würde ja dann bin ich
hier los gegangen und wir wollten auf
die andere seite gehen weil da ein paar
menschen noch mal die halt fand flaschen
gesucht haben und so weiter und
plötzlich kam dieses auto hier lange
rast das irgendwie schon so also
polizisten hinterher gruppen stehen
bleiben und wir dachten was geht jetzt
glaube ich den polizisten gesagt wo es
lang geht und diese
weil hinterher gereist sind um dieses
auto gefahren haben so mit blaulicht und
sirene angeheizt
dieses gekämpft mit pistole so raus
gedrückt und ich dachte es geht mir
jetzt ab weil der typ also ich glaube er
hat gar nicht gehört hier muss ich mal
kurz zu machen ich glaube er hat gar
nicht gemerkt dass die inhalt wirklich
mit vor der ist ja bestimmt 80
durchgeführt hat und ich meine da darf
man 30 waren dass sie ihnen geblitzt
haben oder noch hinterher geschrieben
haben weil ich standen da in seiner ecke
ziemlich versteckt ja und dann sind
nicht halt hinterher gereist habe ich
auf jeden fall so extrem noch nie
gesehen so dann bin ich weiter gegangen
auf die andere straßenseite oder wann
hat welche die pfandflaschen gesucht
haben und der eine typ retter gefragt ob
ich geld hat für ihn dann habe ich ihm
aber einfach so fünf packungen lesen
hotel habituelle zugegeben kekse und 5
ticks oder so dass ich wirklich gefreut
er hat gesagt das war ja wie weihnachten
hier
dem habe ich dann auf den rest gegeben
und ich glaube zwei hotel abu ali sticks
das ist keine werbung an dieser stelle
die hatte ich ja noch für mich übrig zum
essen ich mir schon ins auto gepackt das
sag ich jetzt hier gleich auch noch mal
in die kamera
ja genau das ist das was übrig geblieben
ist und ich habe mal nachgeguckt auf
einem konto ich habe 46 euro ausgegeben
ich glaube wir sind jetzt mittlerweile
schon wieder zu hause
leider ist mir bei der letzten aufnahme
kleiner fehler unterlaufen ich hatte
keinen ton rau auf jeden fall ganz cool
sie haben sich sehr gefreut waren der
erste mal und er hat mich wirklich sehr
gefreut
der war echt sympathisch und ja jetzt
habe ich noch 38 man die polizei
verfolge auch gar nicht darauf mit ton
egal
ja das muss ich ein bisschen nach
synchronisieren und kann alles fertig
die grauen und enthält das war es in dem
video